kind of a curious scene in the bullpen
about an hour ago tyler anderson who
knows he's been dealt out
getting his work in this was supposed to
be his start and there is luis oviedo
who did not learn
for sure that he would be starting until
about
at best at best a couple of hours ago
that's a nice start for luis oviedo his
first big league start
this is his 13th major league game
now it is narvaez that balls hit well
narvaez will watch this one fly out of
here
a two-run home run omar darvaez gives
the brewers a jolt
and first inning runs on the board for
the brew crew tonight
well the much anticipated return of
lorenzo
kane kane sends that one in the air
right center that's going to fall a
little flare
and garcia all the way around to score
that's a lorenzo kane hit if i ever saw
one
he just muscled one into right center
and it's three nothing brewers in the
first
good to see that smile isn't it lorenzo
cain that ear to ear grin
there you go fred anderson always in a
hurry
he's ready to go key brian hayes
hitting second in that pirates batting
order
and down he goes anderson makes quick
work of him a strikeout
two up two down here in the first inning
it's brian reynolds
this is the most dangerous bat in the
pirates batting order now minus frazier
face brian reynolds as often as you can
with nobody on base
and a swing at a miss anderson's got
good stuff early
marvaya's with a two run homer last in
it got the bases loaded here
nobody out in the second
it's that one on the ground through for
a base head finds the hole this is going
to bring in two runs
anderson and wong score and narvaez has
four
ribbies already all the diamonds coming
on the fastball
tomato just can't get the curve ball
over for strikes enough
the strike rate here fastball down and
nobody is able to find the hole in the
right field
garcia walked in the first inning
back-to-back walks after the narvaez
homer
brewers have him at first and second
with nobody out
and that ball is scalded to center field
way back
reynolds it is off the wall
adamus was tagging he's got a little
late start but he'll score
easily and it is a booming double by
avi garcia it is six to nothing
milwaukee
an rbi double four garcia gives him 59
ribbies this year
tales faces mirrors first pitch swinging
ground ball it eats up newman it's into
left center
a base hit one run is in they'll wave
around garcia here comes the throw home
it hits the mound not in time
rowdy teles greets mirrors with a
two-run single
eight-nothing brewers hit that one right
on the screws
today not much of a chance for kevin
newman check this out i mean tellez
left-handed hitter another fast ball
down the middle polanco
hits one on the ground right to teles
fires to second the return feed
is in time nice play by rowdy teles
and to left gamma coming on and look at
that catch by ben
gamel sensational
playing against his former team that's a
great jump
great timing on the dive leaving his
feet
one and two the count runner at first
kane bounces one through a base head
look at lorenzo
just finding the holes he's hitting them
where they ain't vintage
kind of slices one into right field
claws are out for lorenzo kane
and it is so good to have him back good
two-strike piece of hitting by lorenzo
trying to shoot that ball in the right
field
right off the end of the bat lazy fly
ball to kane
out number two
and right off the end of the mat wong
flips it over to adamus and that will
retire the side
still ain't nothing brewers
2-0 it's sharply through for a base head
avi garcia with
two hits tonight man he just stays hot
third time on base for garcia
his last 20 games he's got 26 hits
that includes four homers hitting well
over 340.
and he's been really good
and a swing and a miss a wipeout slider
from
brad anderson strikes out hayes for out
number two
strikeout number three his best game
of the season bouncing ball nice
play arrears long throw is a good one
look at luis urias with some vertical
leap heck of a play to end the inning
first ball swinging and that is kane
slides and makes the play
i guess he's all right i'm not today in
pittsburgh
in lorenzo kane's first game back check
this out watch him
that first step is so important on a
play like that able to make the catch as
it
trying to get the ground you see him
shaking his head not today
made that one look easy i mean the
there's seven back of the brewers
they're six
back of the second wild card spot
castro pops it up
and kane makes a play for the hour
swing and a miss got him with a fastball
a shot in the left bradley will make the
play
and hunter strickland a one two three
eighth inning kyle
keller facing raleigh tales and now
keller
and celeste turns on one down the line
got a chance
and it's up and gone over that 21-foot
wall
rowdy to liz that was an amazing swing
on a pretty good pitch
and that breaking pitch down and in it
just went down
nice easy swing and knocked it out of
here even in a nine-nothing game
gotta get out 27 here gustave deals
and did he go he does
pierogi time for mark carlson and the
ball game is over
brewers win tonight improved to 59
and 42.